hey guys listen uh i wish ivermectin
worked for covid i i wish
hydroxychloroquine worked for covid i
wish
a z pack uh zithromycin worked for covid
i i really do because these things are
cheap and ubiquitous but we have to
operate in the real world
and no matter what
marjorie taylor greene or joe rogan or
anyone says about a medication
the way we determine whether a
medication works for kovid is you do a
randomized controlled trial with a
placebo arm and then it's peer reviewed
and published and then we have data
okay
it's not some doctor in france gave
hydroxy to 30 people that's not that's
not the way we do it okay we look at
peer-reviewed rcts
we now have that for ivermectin we have
a study just published called efficacy
of ivermectin treatment on disease
progression among adults with mild to
moderate covid and comorbidities we have
a study
read the study it's not super long it
will tell you everything you need to
know about ivermectin for covit the
question that the study asked is does
adding ivermectin to the standard of
care
because remember you always want to test
things against the standard of care does
adding ivermectin to the standard of
care reduce the risk of severe disease
in patients with covet and comorbidities
well the findings in this open label
randomized clinical trial of high-risk
patients
with covet in malaysia
a five-day course of oral ivermectin was
administered during the first week of
illness
and it did not reduce the risk of
developing severe disease compared with
the standard of care alone that this is
called this is a science okay this is
what we call a science
conclusions and relevance in this
randomized clinical trial of high-risk
patients with mild to moderate covid
ivermectin treatment during early
illness did not prevent progression to
severe disease
the study findings do not support the
use of ivermectin for patients with
covid19 this is it
now
would be the responsible
time if you promoted ivermectin to make
sure your followers know it doesn't work
because there are lots of people who
only get their medical advice
from people like you know hannity
joe rogan whoever
so they should now say we've been
wondering about ivermectin we have a
proper
peer-reviewed
rct
ivermectin doesn't work we tested it now
there are some people who will say yeah
but david that was only tested on people
over 50 with comorbidities those are the
people at risk like the same people who
say take ivermectin
are the people who say
you don't need to worry about this if
you're healthy or young you just don't
and and that's mostly statistically true
so
why would you want to test divermectin
on people who don't need to do anything
to recover from covid with no problem
whatsoever so we need treatment for the
people more likely to die that's why it
was tested on these people by the way
for things that do work
it's not just that anything cheap
david's against anything that was
mentioned early david's against
vitamin d
we've been talking about vitamin d and
covid for a long time and it's not clear
whether taking vitamin d is protective
or whether getting covered lowers your
vitamin e but there is now a study
which says vitamin d levels appear to be
important when it comes to covin
a new study that considers pre-infection
vitamin d levels
confirms their link to severe disease we
have identified that yes it's not just
covet lowers vitamin d if you have a
lower vitamin d level before getting
covered your risk of severe covet is
higher now
the researchers say
the findings don't necessarily
imply vitamin d treatment will
impact outcomes but they suggest
maintaining a normal level of vitamin d
this is cheap this is a great thing
right i tested myself for vitamin d
right at the end of winter of 2020 when
this was all getting going because there
was the suspicion that there might be
something vitamin d related i my vitamin
you want a vitamin d level of 30.
i tested myself and i was at 30.
so from october through april
i supplement vitamin d a thousand units
per day i checked with my doctor my
doctor said that amount is fine you're
not going to experience vitamin d
toxicity that's a great thing to do it
may or may not be protective but having
a good vitamin d level can't hurt and
it may be something that is worth doing
and it's really cheap the right loves to
say no one wants to recommend cheap
stuff like ivermectin that you can do
now vitamin d is cheap and it sounds
like it's worth doing
of course talk to your doctor before
starting it there might be something
about your situation where your doctor
would say don't supplement vitamin d but
vitamin d is really cheap and it is now
being looked at more and more strongly
so what i want is to do things that are
shown to work
and that's the most important thing
ivermectin study
doesn't work for covid
anybody who promoted it should make sure
their followers know we have a study and
it doesn't work don't seek out
ivermectin for covet uh we'll have more
on this on our instagram which you can
find at david pakman show we'll take a
very quick break